hey there and welcome to this lesson on
atmosphere in motion design my name is
cameron and you are watching motion
science
and we're going to start off with this
lesson on atmosphere by
looking at some form that's what we're
going to start with we're here inside of
cinema 4d and i'm not going to go over
everything that i did to create the
scene but it's a very very simple scene
what i brought in is i imported in a
bridge which we can see right here
it's just a free model i found off the
internet internet it was a common
creative commons file um very simple
model just found it for free somewhere
downloaded it
and i also created a very simple
metal texture that i'm not going to go
into but you're welcome to open up this
texture and just kind of look at it it's
a very very simple metal texture with a
little bit of a bump map on it
uh and that is basically there's a
a light
which is in our scene which is just
hovering above our bridge right here
it's very simple light
and there's a camera and there's a null
object and the null object's here
so that if i want to place anything
inside of my scene with an after effects
i kind of know
where the null is sitting
inside my scene so it's not totally
necessary but if i go into my camera
view here and i select my camera you're
gonna see there's a keyframe here at the
beginning and there's a keyframe here at
the end
and it's just a very simple move so if i
click play
we're just
pushing upwards or trucking upwards i
believe it's the correct term i could be
wrong
i believe it's called a truck and we're
just moving upwards that's it it's 240
frames long
it's 24 frames per second which means
that this animation is 10 seconds long
and if i
click render real quick here you're
gonna see that this texture it's just
kind of like a rusty
metal texture just to give it some
definition like i said this is not
uh the best texture to use for this i'm
by no means a texture expert i just
literally brought in a bridge model
grabbed a metal texture dropped it on it
added a light
and set it up to render
i rendered this out as a png sequence uh
also worth noting this is a 2048 by 1080
comp it's not 1920 by 1080. i did that
just because i wanted to have a little
bit wider frame a little bit more
cinematic frame uh but you could do this
at any size
uh it's 240 frames long like i said the
output i rendered this as a png sequence
uh 16 bits per channel it's an alpha
channel included and i saved it out uh
if you're using cinema 4d lite
i'll show you how you can use this
incidental 4d light because you're not
able to
render out uh out of cinema 4d you
actually have to render the the scene in
after effects
so i'll show you that just a second i
also have ambient occlusion turned on
which is under effects here and that
just creates a little bit of
shadow extra shadow
at the points where
um the different polygons connect
so it just creates a little bit more
realistic shadow
that's all so
the scene is saved i rendered it out
ahead of time because it did take a
little bit of time to render this guy
out
so
that being said i'm going to jump over
here into after effects
and i've got my cinema 4d file imported
i also have my
render sequence imported uh just to show
you if you're using cinema 4d lite all
you have to do is import the 3d the
cinema 4d file
and drag it down onto your timeline
and
you will be able to
see the scene and if you want to see it
in its final glory you're going to
change it to current
and that is going to render it out at
full res so that you can work with your
file
you can do everything else i'm doing
here in this
project
you're just not going to be using a png
sequence you're going to use the cinema
4d file
so that is all you have to do so i'm
going to work with the png sequence just
because it's a quicker process and this
has already been rendered right so i
already rendered this out
whenever you bring a
png sequence into after effects for
whatever reason it defaults to
30 frames per second which you can see
up here so i need to right click
interpret that footage main
and we're going to say
24 frames per second click ok and now
you can see it is 24 frames per second
it's bringing it it's reading it
correctly so i'm going to drag it down
in my timeline here and i'm going to hit
command
k
and my timeline is called our
composition is called the bridge you can
see it's 2048 by 1080 let's make it 10
seconds
1001 extend out
and now we can see
there is our 3d renderer as a png
sequence like i said it has an alpha
channel and you can see that here where
it says plus straight that means there's
an alpha channel so if i come down here
and turn on transparency grid
there is our alpha channel
that is so that we can
bring in some of our assets like
the ground fog here and take it below
the bridge and you're gonna see it
behind the bridge
or i can take it in front of the bridge
and it's in front of the bridge okay
so
let's start here
and before i get too far i want to tell
you that this
element is from action vfx there's a
link
in the description
for action vfx if you want to get more
of their footage and see what they have
definitely click on the link
um
they are kind enough to let us use this
footage
for our example here to show how to
build atmosphere
um so thank you to action vfx and
definitely check them out
so we're talking about atmosphere and
atmosphere
to me a lot of times has to do with
smoke and fog and things like that which
is what i have here right it's called
ground fog three it's a 4k file so it's
huge right so if i wanted to scale this
guy down
you can see
that's the full shot right
so
awesome awesome stuff when we apply this
over the top of like this bridge
or behind this bridge
it immediately gives us
a really interesting some really
interesting depth and some really
interesting atmosphere right
so let's take it back over the top and a
lot of times people will just set this
to something screen
and you can see
you know there it is it's screened over
the top of our footage but the problem
with this technique is that it actually
makes
the white values brighter in our footage
which we don't want
so i can take a screenshot here
and we'll come back to this okay so how
i want to treat this is i want to go
back to normal
and i'm going to go up to effect
channel
and go down here to shift channels
and under shift channels i'm going to
say take alpha alpha
from the luminance and that's
looking at the black and white values
here so we'll take it from the luminance
and immediately
you can see okay now all of a sudden
there's there's alpha channel here in
the fog
and it's not making
this bridge brighter in the background
so
what i could do now is i could go to
effect and i could go to
generate
fill
and this is what's cool is we can
colorize the fog so if i wanted it to be
you know straight white
like it was there it is right so this is
a better way to approach compositing fog
or smoke
versus screen and i'll show you i'll
switch to my snapshot
you can see there see it's not a huge
difference but you can see
depending on your shot it's going to be
brighter
in certain areas or not so this is just
a little bit more realistic way to
approach
using fog and smoke for atmosphere
so we're going to stick with this for
now
[Music]
and i forgot to mention that what we're
building here is based on
something i saw from the alienist
which is right here this is a really
powerful title sequence absolutely love
it
and
i just love the overall vibe the overall
feel
lots of atmosphere
and we've talked about this piece
but when we get to this bridge shot
right here
this is what really inspired me to make
something in this vein i thought it'd be
fun to kind of do something like this so
again you can see like there's
there's a lot there's obviously it's
green right a green color grade there's
some texture moving in the foreground
um there's kind of like this stop motion
feel to it everything's very flickery
and um
kind of like a posterized time kind of
look so that's what we're kind of going
for here on our bridge you know we're
making it our own right but it's highly
inspired from the alienist title
sequence so with that being said i'm
actually going to go in here and make
this
fog
um more on the green range i don't want
it to be overpowering but maybe
something like that we'll see
how we can always come back to it
uh the next thing we're gonna do
is
if you play this back and i'll switch to
half rose here
but if you play this back you can see
that the
bridge has has a
movement to it
but like look at the top here
of the fog it just stays
in the same place
it's not reacting to the camera
and it looks
very fake
i'll play this back in real time
so you know there are times that you
could get away with with kind of faking
the move
with how like if we were to just like
add a key put a position keyframe on the
fog
that could work
and kind of make you know fake it but a
better way to approach this is to
actually bring in the cinema 4d file
just like this
and we are going to extract the scene
data from the cinema 4d file so we're
going to hit extract you're going to see
down here it brings in a light which we
don't need
and a camera
okay so let's go ahead and delete our
cinema 4d file we don't need it anymore
so now we have a camera in our scene
and let's take this ground fog
let's make it 3d
and you can see it disappears
and that's because of a thing inside of
semi-40 where it puts after effects is
kind of weird and the fact that it puts
the center point
in 3d space whatever it's like
it's you take the um
like the width is 20 48 you divide that
by two which is 10 24 and you take the
height which is 1080 and you divide that
by two and that's 540. that's how after
effects figures out what the zero point
is of 3d space whereas cinema 4d looks
at it as zero
zero
and zero okay so now you can see our fog
is back into our scene at zero
it's quite large
so let's shrink it down
[Music]
way down
and you can also see that
the rotation is
off right if we go to a 2 view here
there's our camera there's our
um center point of our fog and there's
our camera at an angle
shooting this way
so i'm going to
just rotate this hit rf rotation rotate
it on the y
and i'm just going to rotate it
something like that
uh if i look at the r rotation here
actually i can see that the y rotation
is negative 43.7 and we're at negative
43 so let's actually go
0.7
and we should be lined up uh pretty
close to
how it should look correct
i think
i think we may have to adjust it again
uh but let's go back to p for position
and let's take our x value
[Music]
and
let's kind of move it let's move the y
down and you can see how fast this moves
because it's so close to the camera
uh going back to the two views here you
can see how close this is to the camera
and that's you know that equates to
very fast
movements uh on the screen right so uh
let's actually let's move it actually
closer to the camera i'm going to do
this because i want to create more
parallax
uh in our scene
actually not maybe that's too much it
doesn't have to be very much
maybe something like that
go back to one view
um and looking at the rotation i'm
actually just going to go and rotate
this even more so it kind of
looks i'm looking at the
z value here and i'm looking at the line
the edge
of the bridge here and i want these to
be a little closer
so
maybe right there
now if i play it back now you can see
instantly look how that fog
is moving down
with that bridge right now it's more
glued to the scene it's part of that
scene it looks more realistic
uh this is actually more like of a
lesson on compositing
than it is atmosphere
but the point of this is that
this fog is what's creating this
interesting you know look to this piece
without it we can add some textures and
we're going to do that
but
you know it's pretty boring right and
then we just add some atmosphere and it
completely changes the look
so now i'm going to command d to
duplicate i'm going to take this layer
behind
the bridge
and
i'm going to push it back
so that's a little bit farther back in
space we're going to create more
parallax this way
and you can see
that
it's not quite you know the top is okay
because the fog is not extending off the
edge of the frame but you do need to
watch out if you're using some different
footage
and pieces of
elements of the fog are going off the
screen off the
layer you're going to get some clipping
up here so you need to be careful about
that
so
that's looking okay
one thing we're gonna do as well is
we're going to offset the time of this
fog so it looks like they're kind of two
different
uh fog layers even though we're using
the same fog we're just offsetting the
background fog so that it starts at a
different place and it ends at a
different place
let's try and increase the size of the
background fog here i really want to
fill the frame with it and the same with
the foreground fog
you have to be really careful with how
much you
you add to this
but something like that
and i'm gonna go ahead and duplicate the
fill and turn off the original because i
like that green but let's go back to
white for now
and same for the background just
duplicate it and let's go back to white
as well
and turn off that green
yeah that's looking better
definitely looking better i'm gonna go
back to the foreground here and go to
two views again
kind of see where okay
there we go so let's bring in some
texture texture can also add to
atmosphere
so let's drop this guy in
make them 3d
go to position and set it to zero
tab zero tab zero
and we're gonna set the rotation as well
on
this guy we're gonna see what we're at
negative let's make it even let's do
negative eighty
and rotation
negative 80.
and then the rotation this guy will be
negative 80.
and
let's make sure that we've got
let's bring this guy
um i did the wrong rotation there i was
wondering what's going on
y is negative 80. there we go
we're going to bring this guy
way up close to the camera so it's
there's our fog layer right there okay
here's our our new layer here so this is
the foreground fog this is the
background fog and pretend that the
bridge is sitting right here
so we've got our other fog or our
texture layer here let's scale it down
way down
and let's set this guy to
screen
and let's pull this over
so you can see a little bit better here
what's going on
and i'm gonna move i don't like this
white edge here
something like that so you can see
i mean that's a lot right it's like
right it's in your face
uh it's
i preview this you can see it's almost
like there's this glass texture
over a really foggy glass right over the
top
which is making it more interesting so
this is kind of a combination of texture
and atmosphere at the same time
but you can use texture to create
atmosphere 100
so let's go in here to
color correction levels
and i want to bring some of this texture
out i want to get rid of some of it so
i'm going to play around
with
these values here
[Music]
uh that's a little bit too much because
i do like
i mean it is really interesting go p for
position and let's
maybe something like that maybe screen's
too much maybe lighten
uh that might be closer to it
yeah
now when we get way up here
um i don't like that we can't see the
fog so let's go that foreground fog and
let's bring it up actually that's the
background fog
but let's bring up some of that
background fog as well
maybe there
and foreground fog
zoom out here
yep and now let's back it up and make
sure
now here see here's the problem is that
now the bottom of the fog is not not
down low enough so we need to increase
the scale
so let's go to maybe five
go to the top
yeah looks pretty good let's extend this
out
um and i think the background is okay
for now i think that looks okay
i've got another texture i'm gonna bring
in
and you know what before we do that
let's actually take this foreground
texture let's actually blur it
learn sharpen let's do
fastbox blur
and repeat edge pixels just because
i always do that to be safe so five is
too much
three is still too much
maybe it's a one
hmm maybe it's going to go lower
0.5
or just it just needs just a touch
boy maybe point one let's go point one
very little amount back to the project
fractured glass let's bring this in
before we do that let's actually
duplicate our layer here
and now let's hold down alt or option
and let's drag in our texture drop it
over the top
and hit p for position and drop down
this guy
and let's turn off the effects
there we go
so this has kind of got this interesting
like
his scratchy glass feel to it
and i'm going to blur it just a little
bit i don't need levels on this one
but you can see the top of it we're
losing it there
we got plenty on the bottom so let's
actually
move it up
so the edge of it's just the bottom of
the frame here
and the top or still is in the top so we
need to scale it up
let's do a three
and now we're good
plenty of room up here on the top
and we've got some room down here
perfect let's add a new adjustment layer
and this will be our
stylize
cc vignette
and we're going to really crank up the
vignette amount here
and
i don't have to keep this centered so
let's actually drag it over to the side
here maybe up in this area
and that's going to be our focus is up
in here and the reason that's gonna be
our focus is because we're going to add
um some typography up there
so let's do that
so we're gonna go up to the type tool
here and we're gonna type in
the
bridge
you can spell it right
we're going to select all of it and we
are going to go into
i think
vermin vi no that's not it
the right
is e x o c
i don't know how you pronounce that but
there you go
so that uh yeah looks okay
and we're gonna make sure we've got it
selected over here v for our tool
and let's make it
3d
and bring it below our adjustment layer
which this is our
vignette
and p for position and we'll make it 0
zero
zero
and it's massively huge that's okay
let's go back to our rotation so it's
negative 80 okay r for rotation negative
80
on the y
and then we're gonna scale this guy down
to like
three
and we're gonna take
the
z and push him back here
maybe something like that
and then we're actually going to push
the uh type back behind the bridge as
well so it's something like this
and i'm going to look at the ground fog
in the background layer and you can see
it's at 27.
let's actually make it 50. it's a little
bit farther back and then we'll make
this one
40. so it's kind of
in between the bridge and the fog so now
if we play back
yeah you see a little bit of parallax
there
let me kind of push
i don't want it to sit just a hair a
little bit behind
the the bridge here
and i don't like the rotation
i don't know why did that so we'll zero
it back out and s for scale again and
let's make it a little bit bigger
that may be too big
yeah too big
four
let's actually bring it up
[Music]
go back to negative 80 again
uh we'll leave it like that
maybe we'll have it so it just starts
off frame there out of frame
so just up here and then
it rests right there so that's that's
nice i like that
and i'm gonna go back to zero again i
keep changing my mind here i kind of
like it angled like that
a little bit better
um something i'm not liking is
this foreground fog
it's just not quite moody enough for me
it's not
uh it's not working quite right and
maybe
it has to do
with the shift channel effect let me go
back here to screen
you know i'm going to bite my tongue
here and i'm going to go back to using
screen on this one because it creates
just a little bit more atmosphere there
in the foreground and i like that
so i know i told you the other way to go
about doing it but uh i'm gonna go with
this
approach this time
um
yep i like that
let's also add a new adjustment layer
here so i'm going to colorize this
and we're going to call this
color grade
now i am going to use a third-party
effect here
to get the look i'm going for there's
different ways you could do this you
could use color correction
lumetri
that would you know go in and change
change the colors get more of that green
tent we were going for
but i'm going to use magic bullet looks
this is an old favorite plugin of mine
that comes with magic bullet it's it's a
plug-in set i've had forever
and for any of you who know me who have
heard me speak
um you'll hear me talk about using
sapphire and red giant those are my two
sets of plugins that i think every
motion designer should have
red giant and boris effect sapphire so
keep that in mind
so i'm on analog tribe here and i found
some really interesting looks in this
pack you can go a lot of different ways
that's really nice
flip flops is very moody
record labels really nice
ooh i really like that a
lot that's really nice too i like how it
kind of
blows out the center
creates a lot more interest in the
center
oh that's nice for a nice black and
white look maybe we'll go with that i
really like that
sanborn
restoration
[Music]
that's
real moody
ice pick
wow there's just some really pretty ones
in here you can see why i like to come
to this for certain
reasons for certain projects
um
let's go
boy
let's go with flip-flops let's do that
one
we're just gonna hit that preset click
okay
and
it's already starting to look pretty
nice
so let's go ahead and preview this
okay so there we go so the the opening
of this looks really nice
these these scratches are way too much
the background atmosphere is really nice
i'm i love the atmosphere here in the
foreground at the beginning
at the end
i'm losing some of it right i want to
see more of it up in here uh just to
give it more mood to make it moodier
um so let's start here with the
is it the fractured glass yeah that's
the one and i'm kind of losing
i've totally lost this guy
why is that
because he's right there
let's go back so there it was there
maybe we'll go back to screen
yeah so we'll bring it back in through
screen lighting was just too light
and then we're going to go back to the
fractured glass here
and we're gonna try and
reposition it
there was uh there was a section of it
that i really liked a lot
um
maybe
so that brings in some more of it so
like i like it just up here
kind of in the corners
again it's
that's nice but again i think it's too
much
and i'm looking i'm paying close
attention to this edge here to make sure
that there's no scratches being cut off
and there it is they're being cut off
right there
so let's increase the size to four
um and see how that looks so there's a
ton of
atmosphere there which is okay because
then we can spend a little bit more
focus up here on the bridge
and you know i want to add glow to this
you know i do
we'll get there
uh the bridge a little too bright let's
go to effect color correction and we'll
go to curves and we're just going to
drop
this down in here so that's with and
that's without just
darkening up a bit let's look here
um let's add another point
maybe that
we're also going to go to
[Music]
this texture
and we are going to apply a tent to this
texture it's way too white
uh so let's just find kind of like a hot
spot like a brown here
and then what we can do is we can
brighten it up all right so we'll bring
up the brightness here
something like that we're going to copy
this tent
and we're going to paste it on the
fractured glass
as well so they're not quite so hot it
looks a little bit more i guess part of
the same piece
i like that
let's take the ground fog let's
duplicate it
why did that create a lot of
mood there
but it's too much let's go to t for
opacity
and let's bring down because we just
want it to be a little bit so maybe 55
off on off on
maybe still too much let's go down to 35
34
off on
uh i think i could work with that for
now
i bring it up or i bring it down
maybe bring it down
yeah i like that uh let's also go to
layer new adjustment layer and we'll
call this
posterize posterize
take this to the very top
and we're going to apply effect time uh
posterize time
and i found in my test i really liked 14
for the time
uh so this is gonna give it more of a
steppy kind of stop-motiony feel to it
and we're still at half res but uh
you can see there what a change it makes
to it right let's also
you know i got to add it
let's also add another adjustment layer
and we'll just call this
effects
and i'm just going to apply my two
typical effects here which are
under sapphire lighting
actually let's try
plug in everything if you don't have
sapphire you can use a deep glow and
that is not going to work
no
so uh how about if we try stylize
hello
and
let's see here let's make the radius a
lot bigger
and let's make the intensity a lot
smaller
and
let's see here
it's just a little bit
um and it doesn't look too bad
but i'm going to go ahead and put on my
favorite which is
sapphire lighting s glow
like i said if you want to be a pro this
is where i would go
um
maybe something in there and then i'm
also going to go to the bridge apply
effect
uh blur and sharp and it's way too crisp
right it just doesn't it it's nice in
the shot but it's way too crisp so let's
add a gaussian blur of three
uh that helps so that's
with and without maybe even more let's
double it six
way too much
four
uh let's go back to three
let's also apply
a gl or a uh blur to the bridge
let's make it a three as well
and too much
two
that's what's off
well that's just a little bit
let's try four
let's go to three
and for the bridge we're also going to
use that brown color so if we go to our
textures
and copy that tent
and we go to the bridge we can just
paste it without changing
uh the colors over here we can just
paste so it looks a little nicer
not straight up white
and we're also going to apply under
effects we're going to apply some
another favorite which is
chromatic aberration which is warp
chroma
very very subtle
amount i always just load this preset
for whatever reason
and always just click the very first one
here
load
and we're gonna crank down the amount
still too much so like point
nine eight
i mean you can see what a difference
that makes right so without and width
it just makes it look that much more
realistic maybe 0.985
um yeah we'll go with that for now uh
and we're also going to use a um
magic bullet
no let's see here
is it universe stylize
uh misfire
and we're not going to
use all of this
stuff that's in here so we're going to
use softness yes
no saturation i liked the colors
at uh maybe fading fading's not i
actually like it without fading
uh we're not gonna apply dust
well maybe
yeah we'll apply a little bit of dust
we're gonna open it up and let's just
turn it down though like
three and four let's do that
very small amount we may go back and
take that off flicker sure
uh we don't need the vignette we already
have our own vignette
uh we don't need scratches
uh and contrast let's see here
boy that's a lot of contrast which i
like it but it's just it's too much
so i don't know if we need to go down
down
there's nine
uh you know it's just a little bit maybe
even less let's go five
and let's uh let's save and let's
preview this
okay so here's our preview and it's
looking really good
there's just a couple more things we
need to do here
for one the vignette is too strong over
here it's just a little bit too strong
like here right when it starts it's okay
um but at the end here it's too much
this is too much the scratch here i
don't like that i can see this bottom
foot peg here so i think we're going to
move the vignette maybe up over here or
something i don't know we'll play with
it we're going to scoot this guy over
and we're going to add some grain
and we have to also remember that we're
at half res here so that's something to
you know it's important to keep in mind
so let's
move this guy
oh yeah that's too much
maybe we do just need to kind of center
it up here
so we're at 220 so let's reset this and
we'll go to 220 again
and we're going to look here
and look here
um i think i want to take it up
i want to make the vignette a little bit
higher
so see how i'm kind of getting rid of
this leg here so that's the goal
um
[Music]
and then this this main scratch here i
want to scoot this over which i believe
is
a fractured glass yeah so we'll hit um
p for position
and we'll just scoot it over on the x
so let's see where we were
okay
let's go 72
yeah it just needs to be a little bit
because i still want to see it here on
the edge
so that works uh let's also we're gonna
add we're gonna save
we're going to try adding fading
the fading is actually pretty nice and
then i want to look at funk i don't want
funk on yeah maybe i do want funk on
here
uh but maybe we don't want dust i don't
believe dust
and we're going to apply effect noise
and grain add grain
and we are going to go to
uh final outputs and we're going to
select
not that one
[Music]
maybe this one so that's width
out so very subtle maybe take the
vignette all the way to the top
or not
you can see how much it changes the look
just by reordering the effects
and i'm feeling pretty solid about this
i like it so let's go to full res
let's save
and let's preview
so there we go and you can see that the
the splotchiness i'm assuming it's the
splotchiness here
uh it's over the top so the uh oh apply
funk that's what it is
i think that that is
not what we want to see
and that's because we have so much
texture here in the foreground with all
these these specks here and i almost
feel like actually it's too much at the
top
of the piece but maybe
it's not at the end for sure so maybe uh
what we do is make sure we have the
right one i believe it's this one yeah
uh we could
t for transparency
uh maybe drop the transparency a little
bit
maybe a little bit more maybe 60.
a little bit too much maybe 70.
let's see how that looks
and there we go there is our
piece that we're calling the bridge
and it looks really nice
uh really awesome atmosphere right uh
some added effects like flicker and
things like that over the top maybe the
flickers a little intense um i would
probably drop that back just a hair
um but you can see i'm probably gonna do
that before i package this project up
you can see going from from like what
you know what this looks like to adjust
back to our original 3d render
right here
um
night and day difference right actually
even take off the effects here
take those off that was our original
and
that's our finished product with
atmosphere
uh thanks for watching as always
my name is cameron and this is motion
science
[Music]
you